hello and welcome to match simplified
I'm Dr Umar Malik and in this video
we're going to talk about polycystic
ovarian syndrome which is also known as
PCOS
polycystic ovariance in Rome or PCOS is
a condition in which a woman's ovaries
and adrenal glands produce more male
hormones than usual these hormones
include testosterone dihydro
testosterone and androstenid ion and
these are collectively known as
androgens now you may be confused that
androgens are male hormones and why
would they be present inside a female's
body but androgens are produced in
females as well however in very minute
quantities they are very important for
proper hair growth metabolism and a host
of other functions
so while all women produce some
androgens women with PCOS have higher
levels of these male hormones leading to
increased hair growth acne and weight
gain
this condition can also cause irregular
periods and can also be associated with
infertility and an increased risk of
miscarriage
PCOS is also linked with a lot of health
conditions like metabolic syndrome
diabetes high blood pressure high
cholesterol levels heart disease uterine
cysts and an increased risk of
endometrial cancer and osteoporosis it
is estimated that PCOS affects almost 5
million women in the U.S alone and it
can wreck havoc on your hormones
metabolism skin and a lot of other areas
of the body
now please note you can just manage this
condition not cure it doctors are still
doing research about how to cure this
condition but till now we do not have a
definite cure for this problem as it is
for many other health conditions like
diabetes heart diseases and cancer so
now what while it is possible for women
to successfully manage their symptoms
with medication hormone therapy or
surgery but if you're looking for
alternatives to traditional treatment
there are several evidence-based
Therapeutics that have been shown to be
effective out of all these diet
modification and having an effective
diet plan has been proven to be the most
effective so in this video we will first
take a look at the science behind how
diet affects your PCOS this will help
you to understand the next part of the
video in which we will talk about some
practical diet tips that you can easily
Implement and in the end we will discuss
in detail about a proper diet plan for
PCOS for both weight management as well
as weight loss however please note that
it is very important to collaborate a
diet plan with your doctor or dietitian
before you start any diet modifications
on your own we also have another video
on our Channel where we have discussed
about four natural ways to manage your
PCOS symptoms without taking medications
you can also check out that video by
clicking on the banner in the top right
corner so let's first start with the
science behind how diet and PCOS are
linked now managing your diet and
caloric intake makes a huge impact upon
your PCOS symptoms and how fast this
disease progresses until recently it was
believed that diet was not an important
aspect in the treatment of PCOS however
since a recent discovery regarding the
role of insulin resistance plays in PCOS
many experts now believe that diet
should be a definite part of the
treatment plan of PCOS some of the most
important factors regarding your diet
that you should focus on include
managing your caloric intake reducing
your saturated fat intake and including
foods with low glycemic index in your
diet
we will discuss about all these points
in detail later in this video
now a study published in the American
journal of clinical nutrition concluded
that the timing of your caloric intake
can have a huge impact on the blood
glucose levels insulin levels as well as
a testosterone levels
women with PCOS who ate most of their
daily calories at breakfast for 12 weeks
significantly improved their insulin and
glucose levels as well as decreased
their testosterone levels by 50 percent
compared to women who consume their
largest meals at dinner time
the effective diet consisted of a 980
calorie breakfast a 640 calorie lunch
and only 190 calorie dinner
spacing the carbohydrates out during the
day will cause less rise in blood sugar
levels that leads ultimately to a lower
insulin peak
now at what time you take your calories
what type of food you eat and how much
you eat all affect the level of insulin
that is released in your blood and
Insulin plays the major role in the
development of PCOS
exactly why and how PCOS develops is not
quite clear however most experts now
agree that insulin plays a major role in
this
insulin is a powerful hormone that is
released by the body's pancreas in
response to eating food especially
carbohydrates
remember carbohydrates are also known as
sugars
when your body senses that there is too
much sugar in your bloodstream it sends
a signal to the pancreas to release
insulin which then transports the
excessive sugar out of the blood and
into the muscle fat and liver cells
where it is converted to energy or
stored as fat depending upon the
requirement of the body
many women with bcos have insulin
resistance this means that the process
of getting the sugar out of the blood
and into the cells is defective and the
cells of fat liver and muscles are
resistant to insulin
the pancreas must secrete more and more
insulin to get sugar out of the blood
and into these cells so high levels of
insulin or
hyperinsulinemia can wreck havoc on the
body causing a huge range of health
problems like polycystic ovaries weight
gain or difficulty in losing weight high
blood cholesterol levels heart diseases
and diabetes the discovery of insulin's
role in this disease has brought into
Spotlight the very important role of
diet planning in the treatment of PCOS
earlier doctors used to treat individual
problems that arose you to PCOS like
erratic Menses excessive hair growth
acne difficulty in losing weight
Etc but now the treatment is mostly
being focused to address the underlying
cause that is insulin resistance if
insulin resistance is present it is best
rated with diet exercise and weight loss
insulin sensitizing medications may be
used as well but most doctors prefer to
start with diet and exercise and then
turn to drugs if needed
since now we have understood why diet
and insulin resistance plays such an
important part in the treatment plan of
PCOS let's look at some of the
actionable steps that you can Implement
in your daily life to manage your
symptoms
number one
your daily caloric intake should be
between 1400 to 2000 calories depending
upon your weight and your activity
levels later in this video we will
discuss about how you can calculate your
daily caloric requirement
number two
try to eat most of your calories in The
Breakfast your lunch should include
lower calories in your breakfast and the
last meal that is a dinner should be the
lightest meal of the day
like we discussed earlier the study
published in the American journal of
clinical nutrition indicated that an
effective diet plan for PCOS included a
980 calorie breakfast a 640 calorie
lunch and only 190 calorie dinner
number three do not eat carbohydrates by
themselves instead combine them with
foods that include proteins and healthy
fats
number four try to select lower glycemic
index Foods as they will cause a slower
rise in blood sugar this is very
important as glycemic index is an
indicator of how rapidly the food turns
to sugar in the blood
the lower glycemic carbohydrates tend to
have more fiber than the higher glycemic
foods for example Bran cereal has a
lower glycemic index than cornflakes in
other words select Reds grains and
cereals that are unprocessed as possible
number five space the carbohydrates out
during the day this will cause less of a
rise in blood sugar and a lower insulin
peak
number six if you feel hungry after
eating a light lunch or dinner you can
try one very effective solution that has
always worked for me before eating my
lunch or dinner I eat a very small
serving of green salad that includes
carrots cucumbers broccoli and peas
after eating a small serving of salad I
have my dinner or lunch and I feel much
Fuller and less hungry afterwards
so these were some easy actionable steps
and you can start implementing any one
or two from today only and these will
help you a lot trust me now let's
discuss about making a proper diet plan
for PCOS patients no diet plan can be
applied to everyone every diet plan
depends upon the person's weight their
activity levels and their goals of
weight management or weight loss
weight loss is very important in
decreasing insulin resistance in obese
females and since the majority of
females with bcos are overweight
regulating the amount of caloric intake
is very important
to start with you must calculate your
maintenance calorie requirement for the
day
let's look at a simple method of doing
that
so if you are moderately overweight and
Physically Active you should multiply
your weight by a factor of 15. and if
you are highly overweight or obese and
you do very less physical activity you
can multiply your weight by a factor of
10. for example a 30 year old female
with a weight of 145 pounds who
exercises three times a week for 45
minutes she would multiply her weight by
15. therefore her maintenance caloric
needs are approximately
2175 calories per day
and similarly if we take an example of
the 30 year old female with a weight of
190 pounds who is not physically active
she would multiply her weight by 10.
therefore her maintenance caloric needs
are approximately 1900 calories a day so
like I said earlier this is your daily
maintenance caloric requirement
that is if you eat these much amount of
calories every day your weight will
remain stable
but since most females with PCOS are
obese weight loss is very very important
weight loss is actually the key to
decreasing the insulin resistance in
obese females with PCOS now lose one
pound per week you must subtract a value
of 500 from your daily maintenance
calories for example in the second
female with the daily requirement of
1900 calories to lose one pound per week
she has to take 1400 calories per day
and in the case of first female with the
daily requirement of
2175 calories to lose one pound per week
she must take
1675 calories per day I hope you got
that
similarly if you want to lose 2 pounds
per week you have to subtract 1000 from
your daily caloric requirement
remember it is not recommended to eat
less than 1200 calories on a regular
basis as this may slow down the
metabolism and can be nutritionally
inadequate also
now let's look at a meal plan for a
requirement of 1500 calories per day and
see how you can space your caloric
intake throughout the day which will
lead to a slow rise in the blood sugar
levels and a lower insulin peak like I
said earlier that breakfast should be
the heaviest meal of your day but for
many females this cannot be practical as
they can't eat a very heavy meal first
thing in the morning
so we will divide our meal plan in three
meals and two snacks
I will also mention some of the healthy
food options that you can choose from
for your breakfast you should eat around
220 calories which includes around 25
grams of carbs you can choose from a
variety of healthy food options like
oats whole eggs different types of
berries like blueberries blackberries
raspberries and almond milk or oat milk
are also good options
in between breakfast and lunch you can
eat a small snack of about 180 calories
which can include a serving of fruit
like guava kiwi oranges apples or any
fruit you like you can also take a scoop
of protein powder try to put it in a
blender and add some fruits and make a
smoothie out of it it will keep your
stomach full and it is very low in
calories
for lunch you should eat about 490
calories which includes around 37 grams
of carbs like we discussed earlier try
to eat a small serving of green salad
before eating your lunch this will make
you feel more Fuller and you
automatically start to eat less
afterwards
try to include foods with a lower
glycemic index like brown rice whole
grain bread or Roti quinoa soya curd and
sauteed veggies like broccoli spinach
kale bell peppers and other green
veggies
if you eat non-vegetarian food then it's
a very good idea to include about 100
grams of chicken breast or a serving of
fatty fish in your lunch lean chicken
and fish are the best sources of protein
and like we discussed earlier it is very
wise idea to combine your carbs with
some proteins as this makes you feel
Fuller and you don't get that sudden
feeling of hunger after one to two hours
of having your lunch then in the evening
have a light snack containing about 180
calories and not more than 23 grams of
carbs you can include foods like green
Sprouts fruits like bananas and a
beverage like green tea with wheat rasks
other options for an evening snack
include yogurt nuts like almonds walnuts
pistachios chia seeds flax seeds and
boiled eggs
you can also include coconut water in
any of your snacks it is proven to be
very healthy and hydrates the body
it also contains essential minerals that
our body needs after that have a light
dinner of about 400 calories which
should include not more than 27 grams of
carbs try eating a small serving of
green salad before you eat your dinner
other foods that you can include in your
dinner include whole flour bread or
rotis mixed veg curries beans eggs fish
chicken breast
Etc
so this was a comprehensive meal plan to
lose weight in PCOS but if you find all
of this information very complex I would
like to introduce you to the weight loss
Mastery Program online
which is a specifically designed course
for females with pcod who want to
achieve sustainable weight loss and
improve their overall health
this weight loss program is based upon
latest scientific research and includes
personalized meal plans tailored
exercise routines and lessons from
experienced professionals I understand
that pcod can make weight loss
challenging but with the right guidance
and support it is possible to achieve
sustainable weight loss which will help
you to address the underlying hormonal
imbalances also that contribute to pcod
weight gain and developing healthy
habits that will improve your overall
well-being one of the best parts about
this program is that it has a 60-day no
question asked money back guarantee so
if this program doesn't work for you you
will get a full refund so you should
definitely try this as there is nothing
to lose except wait of course
click the link in the description below
to get 20 off on this course
and before ending this video we will
just talk about some foods that you
should definitely avoid in PCOS
you should definitely avoid processed
foods and foods containing refined sugar
and refined flour like white bread white
rice white potatoes pastas
Etc
sugary drinks also lead to a massive
insulin Spike because they have lots of
refined sugars so it is a very good idea
to just avoid them
some other food products that you should
consume include fried foods like potato
fries chicken nuggets sweets like cakes
cookies and chocolates
thank you for watching this video on
diet and pcod brought to you by Matt
simplified we hope that this video has
helped you gain a better understanding
of how diet can play an important role
in managing pcod in our next video we
are going to talk about excessive facial
hair growth in PCOS patients also known
as hirsutism make sure to check it out
remember pcod is a complex condition
that requires a holistic approach to
treatment which includes a healthy diet
regular exercise Stress Management and
medical treatment if necessary it is
important to consult with a healthcare
professional before making any
significant changes to your diet or
lifestyle
don't forget to like And subscribe to
our channel for more informative videos
on Health and Wellness thank you so much
for tuning in and I will definitely see
you in the next video
[Music]